hello there guys hope you're going well
so we have a leaked scene from the
mandalorian season 3 which was filmed
behind the scenes this comes from the
source bespin bullet which will be
linked in the description below but this
video is showcasing bo katan fighting a
fellow mandalorian now the mandalorian
that she is fighting does bear a lot of
resemblance to axe wolves which was a
mandalorian we saw in mandalore in
season two so perhaps boca tyne has gone
a little bit evil now or perhaps axe
wolf or whatever mandel orange has fired
in here is secretly working for the
empire or has gone bad himself this is
just one theory but another theory that
has been going around is that the
bogotan might be fighting off a
different member of a different clan
because it is rumored and we have seen
from behind the scene leaks that there
will be different mandalorian clans in
this season so perhaps all these
mandalorians have a lot of different set
of beliefs so boca time doesn't agree
over the way they think hence the
violence that takes place in this clip
but what do you guys think let me know
in the comment section below and if you
haven't already please do like and
subscribe to see future content thanks
for watching guys